avec nous andrée lamontagne ministre de
l'agriculture bonsoir monsieur la
montagne bon sens et filion soir sur les
principes je pense que tout le monde va
s'entendre aujourd'hui c'est intéressant
d'améliorer l'autonomie alimentaire mais
ce qui compte beaucoup pour bien des
consommateurs c'est le prix est-ce que
vos mesures aujourd'hui
voronine produits québécois plus
abordable mais n'avoir monsieur monsieur
fillion à tout respect le fait que les
produits québécois soit plus dispendieux
plus cher le snap une légende urbaine
on a 90 % des produits qui sont
consommés relais dans les supermarchés
sont des produits transformés en e3 mais
l'entreprise au québec pour la
transformation
il peut arriver des fois potable pour
des conjonctures ou des produits de
niche différencier on va avoir des
débits cook aurait pu élever mais de
façon générale des produits du québec
sont très compétitifs hockey et il m est
ce que c'est la majorité des produits du
québec qui sont très compétitifs et qui
m'aiment coûte moins cher que les
produits importés
bah tout à fait la majorité de nos
produits sont compétitives n'a pas
vraiment on est un exportateur net /
surtout charte de marché la première
raison c'est parce que nous position
compétitive
on fait des produits de qualité et on
fait des produits diversifiés
il peut arriver pour certains produits
qu'effectivement il ya des questions de
16 ans il ya des questions de le
contexte aussi commercial de pratiques
commerciales et fois la part des
distributeurs des choses comme ça de
façon générale de nos entreprises sont
très compétitifs on a 3 mai
transformateur au québec sont autant
d'idées mais l'emploi mais toutes ces
entreprises devront bien pour reprendre
l'expression du premier ministre dans
son point de presse est ce que vous
passez aujourd'hui vous vous demandez
vous proposer un contrat moral aussi
avec les québécois en leur disant il ya
douze pièces dans votre panier
d'épicerie de produits importés des
charges ça pour des produits québécois
vous lancer cet appel aux québécois
tout à fait je vous entends des en
entrée d'abord le 12 dollars comme on
dit de remplacer ça va créer 2.3
milliards de retombées dans l'économie
du québec
un milliard pour les producteurs les
pêcheurs puis transformateurs mais
définitivement cet instant un défi que
je leur lance je me suis lancé à la
maison avec buffet il déjà on voit des
beaux résultats
je te défie que je danse mais le
consommateur ne peut pas être le seul
responsable de la croissance de notre
autonomie alimentaire n'est ce pas le
consommateur non mais la demande
l'objectif c'est de répondre aux besoins
du consommateur alors lier comme une
danse ce qui va se faire entre la
production et puis la demande depuis
l'idée naturellement avec des produits
de qualité à des produits qui sont
compétitifs de sensibiliser les gens
aussi ce qu'on a remarqué c'est de
s'assurer tout l'identification des
produits en magasin ou sur les sites de
vente c'est très important pour que les
québécois ont le venin derniers mois et
cette volonté accrue d'augmenter leurs
achats leur achat de produits québécois
et s'assurer que c'est simple
d'identifier et travailler sur l'offre
c'est produire plus et produire mieux
aussi
vous parlez de productivité
d'automatisation de robotisation comment
on fait ça tous et à toutes les échelles
en temps des très petites entreprises
que des plus grandes entreprises
on a des initiatives au ministère de
l'agriculture depuis quelques années qui
vise d'automatisation robotisation pu
transformer les transformateurs
alimentaires
on est d india pti vaut aussi pour nos
journaux nos producteurs maraîchers
après son prince de recul on n'avait pas
un dit qu'une équipe économique du
alimentaires québec dont conjonction
avec le ministère de l'économie
innovation investissement québec
ces forces sont mises ensemble pour
pousser nos entreprises nos exploitants
agricoles à investir davantage
mécanisation d'automatisation
romanisation pour une productivité
accrue pu aussi un contrôle la qualité
accrue prenons hydro québec hydro québec
est toujours en attente de la régie de
l'énergie pour avoir des tarifs
privilégiés pour les producteurs de
serre est ce qu'un effort de votre côté
supplémentaire pour que la production en
serre puisse augmenter que ce soit
avantageux pour les producteurs
je vous dirais le sans rien dévoiler
monsieur fillion je pense que d'ici
quelques temps vous allez m'inviter
revenir le rater mission que je vous
parle la superbe dit stratégie de
croissance dessert au québec on vendre
ses disques elle capable
oui voulait pas nous dire petit avant
goût
non justement aujourd'hui déjà se
prépare une annonce qui passe
l'extraordinaire lorsqu'on voit sans
regarder pendant quelques semaines
ça va être une belle vraiment une
avancée secteur ces écoles au québec
c'est excellent je compte sur votre
votre promesse par ailleurs je vous
posais une question sur la noce de hands
le gouvernement du québec a prêté deux
millions de dollars à kraft foods pour
ramener la production de ketchup au
québec qui dit ketchup dit tomates mais
c'est des tomates américaine de
californie est ce que ça va pas un peu à
contre sens de ce que vous annoncer
aujourd'hui ça m'importe tu te faire
écouter deux choses d'abord c'est une
production qu'on me dit qu'ils étaient
aux états unis ces rapatriés non
seulement au canada mais c'est rapatrier
au québec on va faire la production de
88% de tout ce qui est le catch up radio
canada il faut comprendre aujourd'hui on
m'annonce par lepoint transformateurs
qui utilisent des tomates québécoise
dans ses produits dans ces quatre chocs
des choses comme ça alors c'est toute
une opportunité pour notre filière
québécoise c'est des volumes immense on
s'entend là-dessus mais il ya
certainement une part de ce volet
blalock nos producteurs vont pouvoir
aller chercher
d'ailleurs des neiges comprend alors
qu'il va pouvoir être faite dans quelles
conditions et du sol parfait notre lien
skype nous dit qu'on arrive à la fin de
la durée de vie utile de cette rencontre
merci beaucoup misé la montagne s'arrête
ici merci monsieur ville ayant mobilisé